- [Instructor] So let's
review our knowledge
of what it means to be an ideal gas.
What key assumptions do we
make about an ideal gas?
Well, the first assumption is
no intermolecular interactions,
and what do we mean by that?
Well, an example of an
intermolecular interactions
are something like, say, a hydrogen bond.
Well, let's say that you
have two water molecules,
two neighboring water
molecules, and that is...
So you have an oxygen with two hydrogens.
We know that the oxygen
end of a water molecule...
And this is the gas form,
so we're talking about water vapor here.
So we know that the oxygen
has a partially negative charge,
and that the hydrogen end
has partially positive charge
and these are attracted to each other.
These are our famous hydrogen bonds.
So that is an intermolecular interaction.
We can think about dipole-dipole forces,
which is similar because of
the polarity of the molecules.
We can think about van der Waals forces.
These various molecular interactions
where just random chance one side gets
a temporary polarity and might be
attracted or repulsed from the other side
of a neighboring molecule.
For ideal gases, and for the
application of the ideal gas law,
we assume that there are no
intermolecular interactions
or, if there are, that it's very....
We assume an ideal gas has none of them.
And, in real gases, in order to
assume they're like an ideal gas,
we assume this is very limited
or that we can assume
they're not happening.
The second key assumption is that
the volume of the gas itself,
the molecules of the gas,
is negligible relative to
the volume of the container.
So, gas molecule volume is negligible.
Now, it turns out there are no gases
that are absolutely true ideal gases.
Obviously, all gases,
their actual molecules,
do take up some volume and there will be
some type of intermolecular interactions
in terms of even van der Waals
forces and whatever else.
But it turns out, under most conditions
that we're dealing with in a lot of gases,
that these are reasonable assumptions.
Or at least many conditions
these are reasonable assumptions.
In particular, these are reasonable....
So, this is reasonable for real gases....
Reasonable assumptions for real gases
at relatively high
temperatures and low pressures.
And, obviously, that's going to depend
on which gas we're talking about how
high of a temperature you
need or how low of a pressure.
Or another way of thinking about it is
these assumptions where gases
become less and less ideal
as you approach their condensation point.
So, if you start to really
lower the temperature or
increase the pressure,
you're more likely to go from
a gas form to liquid form.
And, as you approach
that condensation point,
your gas is going to behave
less and less like an ideal gas.
But, as we've seen in many
videos, if your gas is...
If you can make these assumptions,
then it's reasonable to
apply the ideal gas law.
That the pressure times the
volume of your ideal gas
is going to be equal
to the number of moles
times the universal gas constant
times the temperature measured in Kelvin.
Now, let's, first of all, think about why
this is reasonable for most gases
at relatively high
temperatures and low pressures.
And then, we'll think about
where this breaks down
as we can approach the condensation point
where the temperature is lower
or where the pressure is a lot higher.
So, let's do these three cases.
So, the first...
Let me do it in this color right here.
So, high temperature/low pressure.
Then, I'll do a case of low temperature.
And then, I'll do a case of high pressure.
So, first, why is it reasonable
for real gases to behave this way at
high temperatures and low pressures,
relatively high temperatures
and low pressures.
Well, let me draw a container here.
This is the walls of my container.
Obviously, this container
will be in three dimensions.
But I will just draw...
Imagine it as a cross-section
or a two-dimensional version of it.
And let me draw the gas
molecules bouncing around.
So, it's high temperature.
So, these things are really
moving around quite fast.
But it's low pressure,
so there's not a lot of bouncing,
especially with the
walls of the container.
So, this is a real gas.
Its molecules clearly take up some volume.
And we'll assume that
they're in the real world.
There are some intermolecular interactions
with neighboring molecules.
But, because it's such a high temperature,
these things are really
buzzing around super fast,
you really don't have the
closeness and the time
for these things to really interact.
And the attractive
forces that you might get
from, say, hydrogen
bonding or whatever else,
it really doesn't come into play.
Likewise, since it's low pressure,
there aren't a lot of collisions.
It's reasonable to assume that the gas,
that the volume is negligible
relative to the volume of the container.
At least my brain visualizes
that there's just not...
That the container's huge
relative to these gas molecules.
And so, when we consider
how they might interact,
it's okay to not think about
their interactions with each other.
Either in terms of
colliding with each other
and having this electrostatic repulsion
or they're gonna be so far away
from each other most of the time
that some type of attractive force,
whether it's a hydrogen bond
or dipole-dipole interactions,
that it's not really gonna come into play.
So, this is why, in these conditions,
it's okay, it seems reasonable
that most real gases....
Let's assume the ideal gas conditions
and that we can apply the ideal gas law.
Now let's go into more of the,
I guess you could say, boundary cases.
Let's assume you have low temperature.
So, in a situation with
low temperature....
I'll draw the same container.
We'll draw the same container.
And so, now low temperature.
If you are an ideal gas,
a truly, this kind of mythical, ideal gas,
Well, the temperature
shouldn't matter so much.
But now that we actually
have a low temperature,
now neighboring molecules,
especially things like attractive forces,
are going to have a
chance to come and play.
They're not whizzing
by each other so fast.
And so, if attractive forces
are starting to come in play,
do you think holding the volume constant
and holding the temperature constant
at this low temperature and holding
the number of molecules constant...
Do you think that a real
gas at a low temperature
would have a lower pressure
or higher pressure than a ideal gas?
I encourage you to pause the
video and think about it.
So, it's low temperature.
And so, we're assuming...
So, hold T temperature,
volume, and number of moles
for ideal and real constant.
So, if we were to compare the pressure
of the real gas to the
pressure of the ideal gas,
what do we think it will be?
Well, the real gas, these things are
gonna be kind of moseying past each other.
So, they're gonna have more time to
attract each other with
these hydrogen bonds
and these van der Waals forces.
And so, they might spend more time
bumping into each other or
clumping closer to each other
than they would be
bouncing into the walls.
So, you can imagine, if you
hold this low temperature
constant for the two different situations,
ideal versus real...
If you hold the volume constant,
if you hold the number
of molecules constant,
you would imagine that the
pressure for the real gas
is going to be lower than the
pressure for the ideal gas.
And think about taking
the temperature so low
that you, once again, get
to the condensation point.
Then these things are
going to be moving so slow
that they're going to start
really attracting each other
or they're gonna have a chance that
attractive interaction can overpower,
I guess you could say, the
kinetic movement past each other
due to the low temperature.
And so, you can think of
it, capture each other.
And they could go to a liquid state.
And this would happen
with water vapor molecules
as you lower the
temperature closer to the,
I guess you could say, closer
to the condensation point
or the boiling point, depending on
which direction you are coming from.
Now, let's go the other way.
Let's think about high pressure.
And let's hold...
Let's compare what a real
gas would do to an ideal gas.
But we're gonna compare volume.
So, we wanna compare
the volume of a real gas
compared to the volume of an ideal gas.
And we're going to hold
temperature, pressure, and
number of moles constant.
So, an ideal gas...
Let me draw my container again.
An ideal gas, right over here,
it shouldn't matter
that it's high pressure.
We're assuming these things here.
So, these things are really
knocking into each other
very, very frequently.
Not only into the containers,
but into each other.
And, depending on how much you
view the volume negligible,
for an ideal gas, you think about
more about the interactions
with the container.
But, if the pressure is high enough,
well, then there's so
many collisions going on,
that, if you really wanted to
hold the pressure constant,
especially if this volume
becomes consequential
because there's so many
collisions going on,
well, then if you wanna
hold the pressure constant
for the ideal gas versus the real gas,
you would have to give
the real gas more space.
You'd have to give it more space
because the volume of the molecules
are becoming consequential.
You're starting to challenge
assumption number two.
So, to have the same pressure,
in this case, the same high pressure,
your volume of the real
gas would have to be higher
than the volume of the ideal gas.
So, once again, getting something
really, really, really high pressure
is another way to get closer
to that condensation point.
In general, if you lower the temperature,
increase the pressure, you're getting
closer and closer to the molecules
interacting with each
other, capturing each other
so that you get to a liquid state.
So, the whole takeaway here,
ideal gas assumptions
and the ideal gas law
reasonable for most gases
when we have a high
temperature/low pressure.
But then, when we test those things,
low temperature/high pressure,
well, things might start
to break down a little bit.